from calorie counter portion sizes
we wanted to find out all the
differences between krispy kreme in the
uk and the us
this is food wars
[Music]
in the uk we can get donuts in four
portion sizes
as a single donut
as a three a
dozen or
the life of the party with a double
dozen
in the u.s you can get your donuts in
single two if you get it with a coffee
combo
three pack
dozen look at these beauties or
two dozen
now technically the double dozen isn't
the biggest thing on the uk menu krispy
kreme in the uk will cater for events
like your weddings or your parties
and they can do something called a donut
wall which contains 216 donuts
hanging on pegs on a wall that's 18
dozen krispy kreme will also make you
something called the donut tower it
looks almost like a wedding cake and is
made of around 260
donuts you got to give them a heads up
though because i went to the krispy
kreme today and asked for one and they
said no
also in the usa krispy kreme you can get
mini donuts in 4
or 20. i have to know
in trouble i don't know if we're gonna
make it through the shoot counter these
are so good
this right here is a standard usa krispy
kreme
classic glazed donut i wanna bite into
you
so bad but before that
let's weigh it now we're going to weigh
a glazed doughnut in the uk to see what
it comes to
they're so light in the uk our hot
coffee sizes
are regular and large us krispy kreme
you can get your coffee in three sizes
small medium and large and if you're
really thirsty
get yourself a brew box nice
a large hot coffee in the uk is supposed
to be 16 ounces so we're going to
measure that to find out if that's true
and to make sure that this reading is
absolutely accurate got a big boy
[Music]
okay krispy kreme in the u.s and get
your iced coffees in two sizes
medium and large iced coffees in the uk
also come in two sizes
regular and large they use the same cups
as the hot coffees they ditch the
plastic ones apparently to cut down on
plastic waste
now we're going to measure our iced
coffee black
oh definitely more coffee now besides
donut walls the biggest thing on the uk
menu is this the sharer bundle
it's four dozen donuts and it comes to
41 pounds and 95 pence
this here is the largest single menu
item you can get at a us krispy kreme it
is the meat in greet
two dozen assorted donuts and a brew box
all for 42.95
let's look at nutrition this is a
classic ring glazed donut from krispy
kreme and it contains
200 calories 8.3 grams of fat 12.6 grams
of sugar
and 96 milligrams of sodium that same
doughnut in the u.s
is 190 calories 11 grams of fat 10 grams
of sugar and 85 milligrams of sodium
ours is less with everything except
fat few people can stop after just one
donut so if you decide to have three of
these the calories go up
now you're looking at 600 calories which
is 30 of your daily allowance
and in the us these three donuts are
slightly less in calories it's 570 over
here
but look at how much sugar these three
donuts had it's almost
three-fourths what you should be having
in one day speaking honestly though
if i have these it's not gonna have a
salad for lunch getting a dozen donuts
for you and your friends or just
yourself
that would put you at 2400 calories and
in the u.s
our dozen comes to 2 2280 calories
i would hope you wouldn't eat all 12 of
these by yourself but if you do
i guess that's all the calories you're
going to need for the day i can eat 12
of these
easy another popular doughnut of krispy
kreme is the chocolate glaze
just ignore the sprinkles on ours
because we didn't have any plain ones
now this one is 237 calories and also
beats the classic glazed in pretty much
every other metric probably because of
the chocolate frosting
our us chocolate glaze is 240 calories
so it looks like the chocolate glaze
helped put us over the top what
if you want even more calories in your
donuts how about the uk's chocolate iced
with custard now this one is 289
calories
and ours is 300 calories 300 just this
one doughnuts
definitely
in the uk the most calorific donor is
this one the lotus biscott donut it's
396 calories
the most calorific donut you can get at
a krispy kreme at least in america
is something called the chocolate chip
cookie dough donuts
made with chips ahoy cookies and it is
400 calories
they weren't available where we went the
second most calorific doughnut you can
get at a krispy kreme
is the oreo cookies and cream donut
that's 390
calories also couldn't get it
the third most calorific doughnut
you can get at a krispy kreme in the
united states is the double dark
chocolate donut 370 calories
no and the fourth most calorific
doughnut
you can get us krispy kreme is the cake
batter
donut 360 calories
we got it this is a nice looking this is
like what i mean this is
sprinkles it's colorful oh man i'm
fading fast
i shouldn't i'm gonna drink all those
coffees what about the drinks
well this is a large mocha with two
percent milk and in the uk
it contains 247 calories 16.3 grams of
fat 12 grams of sugar
and 80 milligrams of sodium in the us
our large mocha
is 480 calories 1 gram of sugar and 260
milligrams of sodium come here you
salty mocha dog whoa this is good
i'm surprised i thought i wasn't gonna
like it i normally don't get like
chocolatey drinks
if you get this as an iced coffee it
contains 280 calories 12 grams of sugar
and 40 milligrams of sodium do you want
to get it iced
now the calories are 420 2 grams of
sugar and 190 milligrams of sodium
since the uk and u.s sizes are different
we've calculated it per fluid ounce and
we found some pretty shocking
differences
from the uk to the us there's a 55.5
calorie increase
and 93.3 sugar decrease and a 160
sodium increase
[Music]
way too many donuts on this thing dude
i'm losing losing my
mind and in the u.s our donut is made
up of enriched wheat flour which is
wheat flour niacin reduced iron
thiamine mono nitrate riboflavin folic
acid i'm getting better at this
um water palm oil soybean oil
sugar it contains less than two percent
of each of the following
yeast soy lecithin hydrogenated soybean
oil
salt mono and diglycerides weak gluten
calcium sulfate monocalcium
phosphate yes and bht ah yes
our old friend bht aka butyl hydrolated
hydroxytulene it is banned in the
european union
the international agency for research on
cancer suggests
might i say strongly suggest there is
sufficient
evidence that bht causes tumor growth in
lab animals also according to webmd bht
is also used to treat genital herpes
[Music]
all right dried milk powder egg yolks
yolks
yolks egg yolks cellulose gum calcium
proponent to maintain freshness
ammonium sulfate sorbic acid
dicalcium phosphate sorbitan
monoceturate monocerotates
tocopherols i scratched that i'm gonna
do a tough time on this one
try calcium phosphates dymonium
phosphate and that last guy dymonium
phosphate aka dap not the sequel to wap
it is also used as a fertilizer and as a
fire retardant
so when we have the next wildfire
outbreaks in the state
because it definitely will happen we're
gonna start dropping krispy kremes on
those wildfires
[Music]
solved in the uk a glazed donut is made
of the following
wheat flour wheat flour calcium
carbonate iron niacin
thiamine water dextrose palm oil yeast
salt wheat gluten emulsifiers mono and
diglycerides
sorbitan monostearate raising agents
monocalcium phosphate dicalcium
phosphate
sugar dried egg yolk powder skimmed milk
powder
preservative calcium propionate
stabilizer
carboxymethyl cellulose firming agent
calcium sulfate
flavoring acidity regulators ammonium
sulfate diamonium phosphate
flour treatment agent ascorbic acid
enzyme
amylase anti-kicking agent tricalcium
phosphate
oh ah done done nope there's more
that was the donut now we're going to
talk about what's in the glaze
sugar water antiglycerides
it's a lot of ingredients for a donut
one thing worth pointing out is the
differences in the sprinkles between the
uk and the us
three of the colorings used in the us
are actually subject to restrictions in
the european union and if they're
included in foods they must bear a
warning that they may cause
hyperactivity in children not here
though baby
i'm not here blue one isn't actually on
this list but it's also very hard to
come by in the uk
it was famously removed from smarties in
the uk several years ago and it took
them three years to find a natural
alternative to the blue color which
ended up being spirulina
[Music]
here is everything you can only find on
the menu at a uk krispy kreme
and these are all the things you can get
at a us krispy kreme
let's start with some donuts the first
one we'll look at is this one
the lotus biscoff now lotus biscoffs are
those little biscuits which you usually
get on the side of a cup of coffee
it's like a caramel flavored crunchy
cookie and we're kind of obsessed with
them in the uk
this one comes with some crumbled up
biscoff on the top and i think the icing
also has biscoff in it and there's also
some biscoff injected inside as well
next up we have
this one which is a chocolate dream cake
caramel iced ring donut
nutty filled berry ring donut the purple
lovehearts donut
now this one's been produced in
collaboration with love hearts the candy
as you can see by the very cute phrase
on top this is
a very thing we just got one that says
omg next up we have the caramel
sensation
nutty chocolate now it's actually a
heart-shaped donut with some chocolate
icing on top and importantly it's
full of nutella
it's a little bit underwhelming i wanted
more nutella to come out now
pretty good and these are all the
exclusive items you can get at a us
krispy kreme
okay so the u.s krispy kreme has
so many exclusive usa only donuts
but they're not available in every
krispy kreme so the one we
specifically went to had about a dozen
of those donuts
a original filled chocolate cream so you
can see in the little
white spot there that that's where they
put the cream in there pretty sure
that's an apple fritter
that's a birthday cake i only saw before
chocolate icing
filled with custard yeah that's
definitely a custard one
you can see the yellow in there i'm
gonna assume this is maybe the uh
glaze sour cream cake sugared ring and
cinnamon sugared ring
see there's a claire right here new york
city
cheesecake glazed raspberry filled
oh god oh
[Music]
there's nothing much stuff in here
oh so good
i'm gonna be so sick and i don't care
also the us krishna cream you can get
these
donut holes they put them in these cups
that might be reusable
the uk does not have these as before
mentioned
minis it's usually 20 but the crew got
to them too fast i couldn't stop them
couldn't stop them now on top of the
donuts themselves the uk also has
exclusive ways of presenting the donuts
for example here we have a birthday box
and you can also get a donut with a
customized message printed on it
unfortunately we didn't give them enough
warning
so maybe if the editor can just add one
here that would be great
the krispy kreme in the u.s has a lot of
varieties of hot
and cold drinks you can get your lattes
in a version of
vanilla caramel or white chocolate
and then the ice drinks same rules as
before
everything has a vanilla white chocolate
and caramel version this right here is
the malibu dream it is a strawberry
banana and vanilla
shake tastes okay we actually have
a few more things i forgot oh almost
forgot
get bottle drinks to go krispy kreme in
the uk also offers a range of exclusive
shakes we have
four of them here we have the oreo shake
a
strawberry and cream shake the lotus
biscoff shake
and then this one is a chocolate cream
shake back at it again with the biscoff
like
what's the deal with that why is
everyone so obsessed with this golf i
don't get it
i'm just gonna say i don't like biscoff
and i'm mad that they've put it in so
many things on their menu i'm gonna try
the oreo one because
even though it's sat under studio lights
for several hours it still looks and
smells pretty good
that's very sweet but pretty good we can
also get some exclusive ice cream
options in the uk including a pink
lemonade an original lemonade a frozen
mango
and a coffee chiller although
unfortunately the ice machine was broken
when we went so we couldn't get them
today
and finally apparently you guys can't
get flat whites in the u.s which is
surprising because we drink those all
the time in the uk
it's kind of just like a latte but with
slightly less foam hey thanks for
watching we have a new project coming
that we're really excited about and
we're going to show you a few seconds of
it right now
this is a big mac and this is everything
that's in a big mac
welcome to fast food chemistry i feel
like i'm watching someone
making an explosive this is potassium
aluminium sulfate
soy lecithin calcium chloride potassium
sorbate polyoxyethylene sorbitan
monoliths
so there you have it can you tell which
one is ours well that looks actually
looks pretty good
i'm very surprised by that that's right
we used every chemical mcdonald's uses
to make a big mac but you'll have to
tune in next sunday to see how it turned
out
be sure to subscribe to food insider so
you don't miss it soy
lecithin
did you hear that yeah my stomach's
turned in all these donuts this was
this was a mistake and the best mistake
i've ever made
i don't care how i feel this donuts is
so good